ja das schauen wir auf die beiden Männer
die der messerkiller von Ludwigshafen
getötet hat Jonas und Sascha zwei
Handwerker malermeister einfach so
wahllos niedergestochen und zwar von ihm
ja dem Jungen Somalia der 2015 nach
Deutschland gekommen ist längst
polizeibekannt war wegen
Körperverletzung sein Motiv weiter
völlig unklar es gibt bisher ja ganz
offenbar keinen politischen Aufschrei
über diese Tat von Ludwigshafen die
Behörden die sprechen bisher nicht von
einer islamistischen Tat nicht von
Messer Terror wir wollen darüber
sprechen mit unserer bildreporterin
Claudia Detsch indem wir uns den Täter
noch mal vor diesen Somalia 2015
offenbar zu uns nach Deutschland
gekommen was weißt du über diesen Mann
bisher
wir wissen erst mal hallo was
Ludwigshafen wir wissen dass er 2015 als
Flüchtling aus Somalia kam dass er 2017
anerkannt wurde als Flüchtling dass er
hier 30 km entfernt in einer
Obdachlosenunterkunft wohnt und wohl
längere Zeit hier mit Samira a einer
Mutter von zwei Töchtern
liiert war und diese eben dann wohl
irgendwann mitgeteilt haben hat dass es
ausbauen darüber kam er wohl nicht
hinweg wir wissen über ihn auch dass es
diverse Vorstrafen gibt aber eben keine
sozusagen gravierenden als das
Hausfriedensbruch es ist
Körperverletzung aber keine schwere
Körperverletzung das hat uns der
Staatsanwalt so gesagt und das ist der
aktuelle Stand der Ermittlungen
um ihn abschieben zu können
das ist das Problem ja und er ist ein
anerkannter Flüchtling also insofern
kein schwebendes Asylverfahren mehr
sondern anerkannt
sprechen wir mal über die Opfer Sascha
und Jonas was kannst du uns zu den
beiden sagen
das ist eine unheimliche tragische
Geschichte also uns hat eine enge
Freundin der Familie von Jonas
erzählt dass Sascha mehr oder weniger
das dritte Kind dieser Familie war der
war ja viele Stunden bei Ihnen hat auf
Sascha und den kleinen Bruder früher
aufgepasst sie haben gemeinsam gezockt
sie haben gemeinsam gekocht trotz des
Altersunterschieds und so weiter und
Jonas hat noch einen kleinen Bruder und
wie gesagt eben sascha hat auf die
aufgepasst sie haben ganz viel über
Fußball gequatscht ich habe leider nicht
rausgefunden
von welcher Mannschaft sie die Fans sind
das ging nicht und ansonsten erklärt es
vielleicht auch der Täter ging ja zuerst
auf Jonas los und starr auf ihn ein von
hinten und Sascha wollte ihm unbedingt
noch helfen hatte aber keine Chance lief
dann noch ein bisschen weg und brach
dann zusammen
das ist das erklärt auch jemanden den
ich noch lieber als einen
Arbeitskollegen mag den versuche ich
unter allen Umständen zu helfen
und was die Sache fast noch ein bisschen
noch tragischer macht in der Nähe muss
Jonas Papa gewesen sein die wollten
gemeinsam Mittagspause machen also der
Papa kam zu Sohn und einem Freund der
Familie und die wollten ganz schlicht
gemeinsam Mittagspause machen und der
Papa muss auf die Straße gerannt sein
und zu seinem Sohn natürlich hin eine
Augenzeuge und sagte sie hat noch nie
jemanden so bitterlich weinen gesehen
denn sie konnten einfach nichts mehr
machen ja wohl noch lebt aber auch die
Einträge ja Claudia entschuldige eine
solche Männer
das ist gerade so bewegen wenn du das
erzählst eine solche besondere
Männerfreundschaft ja fast so eine Vater
wie so ein Beziehung dort die
ausgelöscht wurde die beiden starben ja
gemeinsam an diesem Tag diese
Freundschaft wurde ausgelöscht von einem
25 Jahre alten Somalia dort danke dir
Claudia
[Musik]